why McDonald's so I said to McDonald's
listen up
you're doing a hundred billion a year in
Revenue 100 billion you're pulling about
40 billion a year out of the black
community
you're spending about a billion a year
in advertising less than 5 million is
going to Black owned media not to be
confused with targeting
and we as black owned media cannot
survive with that disparity
and McDonald's there's some serious
issues there it isn't just me McDonald's
has been sued multiple times two of them
that I'm aware of by the black
franchisees who have said hey why do you
just keep putting me in the black
neighborhood they've been sued by the
black Executives they've been sued by
the black store employees they've been
sued by the head of Global Security who
spoke at a town hall meeting and said to
Chris kamzinski the CEO of McDonald's
I'm very disappointed about your racist
text messages Chris kamzinski sent some
racist text messages to the mayor of
Chicago and he got caught and he went on
an apology tour and as a part of his
apology to her for getting caught
sending these racist text messages about
Black and Latino families
uh he did a town hall with his
um his employees and the head of Global
Security a black man said I was very
disappointed by your racist text
messages
and that man was fired after 20 years so
he too sued McDonald's and then if that
wasn't enough
an unprecedented vote came down that
none of these lawsuits have anything to
do with me this is the culture at
McDonald's
55 percent of the stockholders at
McDonald's 55 percent mainly white
people
voted to hire a third party firm to
investigate McDonald's for civil rights
violations
that is unheard of
I'm 62 years old I've I've studied a lot
about business I love business I have
never seen that in my life where 55
percent of your stockholders have said
mainly white people there's some
problems here we need to hire a third
party firm to investigate civil rights
and you know violations at this company
and then fast forward I don't know if
you saw in the New York Post this whole
expose the BBC uncovered over a hundred
people in the UK
unbelievable violations sexual
harassment sexual assault racism racial
racial slurs all of this cover-up
and it's like at a certain point but
that's our um culture as opposed to
that's our culture that one company
that's what is happening absolutely
everywhere but as a company I think you
you give yourself responsibility to try
to change the culture absolutely so I
said here's a 10 billion dollar lawsuit
and the judge said the case can go
forward
10 billion 10 billion 10 billion you're
a hundred billion dollar company
you're 200 whatever it is 10 billion
dollars
now get to the table and correct that
deficit and eradicate this culture
this board this direction the board of
directors of McDonald's needs to be
fired all of them because this is the
same board for the most part that had
the previous CF the CEO major issues
with sexual harassment to the point
where they fired him and then tried to
claw back his compensation but if you
personally are suing for 10 billion
dollars what what is that don't you have
to show what the damages are
specifically to you yeah yeah exactly
the years they didn't do business with
us and the money they didn't spend I
mean it's insane and I'm like and by the
way
it's like uh
you know there's not just me there's so
many others where it's black owned media
and McDonald's isn't spinning a nickel
with them and I just say look it's time
to stop the misinformation or bring it
to the Forefront or break and I'm just
putting a light on it
[Music]